question your colleague Richie Torres
has said calling for a ceasefire is a
dangerous double standard that the US
wouldn't hold themselves to so my
question is is if this attack happened
in America would you be calling for a
ceasefire as well vengeance is not a
foreign policy
Doctrine uh we are here to save lives
yes or a no anyone else how many more
killings is enough for you is it a th000
more 2,000 more 3,000 how how many more
Palestinians would make you happy if
they died do you you will you be fine if
all of the people of Gaza were gone
would that make you happy would that be
the thing that makes you proud how many
more Palestinian lives is he comfortable
because I'm not comfortable with
anymore any other questions what do you
say to the Israeli people that feel like
you're telling them to do nothing when
their children are being held hostage by
terrorists